hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to dimension 2 HD now we're
dimension 1 is I don't know but oddly
enough this game was originally made on
the Nintendo DS and it was recently
ported to the PC two days ago with all
new graphics to make it pc worthy now I
don't know a lot about this game but I
mean just judging by this picture here
holy hell that's his read more William
on it so I'm pretty sure that's probably
important so let's get into it I
actually don't know a lot about it so
this is kind of a crapshoot here hmm
waking up in a hospital groggy oh hey
there hi
oh oh yes markiplier how you doing
what's your name ow
William read more oh really
hmm oh I'm better now that you're here
baby
oh oh my cell okay alright then
so William read more that was the name
on the thing the bracelet on the hand
Cobb well you know that was descriptive
enough for you you know what I'm talking
about
hello oh hello okay wait what isn't that
that same nurse from before Hey
I think I'm in jail or someplace for the
criminally insane yeah I saw that blood
stain in this cell here don't tell me
that's mine oh oh I thought I saw a
blood stain in there was that just me or
did I see a blood stain like from a
distance there okay nevermind chapter
one
welcome what was that for God's sake get
out before it's too late William okay
what's happening okay what Wow what's
this
excuse me what the hell just happened
oh okay so I got a knot get chopped in
half by the guillotine let me out let me
out Oh does it do close for comfort
y'all for being a Nintendo DS port this
does not look that bad I mean some
things are pretty polygonal but I can
forgive it for now okay it's a shank
used one to equip it okay cool
what am I doing with Oh oh goodness
gracious okay yeah I'll kill you with
the shank that's lovely
Oh what is wrong as your chest you look
like one of those half-life zom zoms
with the teeth in the chest huh
okay so this is how this game hi
we just carve you up another butthole in
your face and you'll be good to go
how do that to me okay wha
it took me a second to realize what was
going down there oh what is that oh oh
what is that oh no what his voice change
out through his stomach
not as crotch I was really gonna say
crotch but oh oh that is weird
I think I might have taken it kind of
brain surgery did I go through anyway
oh no oh hi hello what excuse me what
time for cutscene huh is this me I'm a
little busy right now
I'm trying to my brain started process
what the hell just happened okay what
huh
bog Leone Oh what is day to me we stay
about my mama
and yes twice yeah so I'm sort of
Russian oh no oh okay here we go
okay what the hell just happened I'm not
even sure what's going on
all right anyway I still got this shank
from the weirdo world
maybe maybe I'm totally insane how do I
open the door
all right click okay right click ah hi
I'm breaking free out of prison I I know
that you probably have a family this was
your last day of retirement um all that
jazz ah good for you first day on the
job last day overtime and take your pick
whatever you know what is really weird
it's really really weird right now
this is harkening back way way long yo
this looks like a level right out of
nightmare house am i is it just me some
people have watched my nightmares
playthrough or play to themselves guard
dressed up like that sorta Holloway with
the two doors ah it bring in some bells
isn't it okay nevermind dedicated the
innovative care bright dawn treatment
center is one of the premier facilities
through the treatment of severe
psychological disorders in North America
our staff is well trained and
knowledgeable at the latest techniques
in the field of psychiatric care all
applicants must undergo a rigorous
eligibility screening to determine their
compatibility with our cutting-edge
treatment plans please fill out the
enclosed form to return it along with
the complete medical history picture of
your crazy family member and anything
else you can provide me to prove is
bongos craziness I didn't even need to
read that
nightmare house 2 was one of my favorite
horror games that I played a long time
ago I mean I just really liked it it
still had like the gun style gaming and
you knows a lot of shooting but that
didn't mean it was bad I mean some
people think that you know amnesia is
king just because you don't do you don't
we use weapons it promotes helplessness
and yeah it does but at the same time
whoa
you didn't even see me how did you know
I'm gonna shank you got a weird half
life to stunner stick actually that's
the second half life to thing I've
referenced today what's going on with
the rough you really how about you get
on your butt oh I'm not a good person am
i and some psychiatric hospital if I'm
prisoners here maybe I am a good person
in I'm just trying to break free but
okay I'm looking up I got the map in the
top right it's actually kind of cool
because it shows highlighted areas it's
a page what passion for 7:30 to 9:00
read more William cowling State Hospital
for the criminally insane allegedly
murdered wife Oh and suffered psychotic
break presented with low level of
function high suicide risk gaff 13
possible schizotypal disorder but
officially diagnosed as an unclassified
mental illness f90 died well which
garden in phase one I don't know what
that be excuse me I get the hiccups I
don't know what that means when I start
talking more regularly I don't know why
like lately every time I do a let's play
it's always like halfway through it at
some point
whoa okay if this is in North America
why there's so many people speaking
Russian or some Eastern European
language Oh
adrenaline here I loved it in left 4
dead 2 it's got to be great here
hey friend would you like the gift of
eternal sleep from a crazy psycho person
oh oh it's a save mirror oh ha ha ha
that mirror
looking at my beautiful face I'm just so
Kourt wait not you though nice though
ok ok
you uh hey you weirdos be weird
somewhere else there's a question mark
on this thing Oh jars of eyes it's one
of these puzzles oh excuse me I wanted
to do that pardon me
oh I see ok yeah I haven't I haven't
done one of these since like oh man the
last time I I did one of these who was
um it was a forest back in I'm trying to
remember the name of it it was one of my
favorite games why can't black and white
you remember for those who play through
black and white there was like well
those puzzles back when I played it I
was younger and stupider so oh oh
I'll finish this later whatever was
wrong inside your head we we let it out
god help us all what oh it's you please
ignore my saying a half William he's a
good remorseful personally I'd like to
share something with you
goodbye William well oh you win oh
that's that thing mr. thing that ain't
that dude ah
you're weird oh you're kind of big I
didn't grab like Oh guys guys I can't
even run but can I run this doesn't seem
like a fair fight I mean I know I'm a
stone-cold badass and everything but um
you could all right you know I come here
you old dude come on get down I'm okay
yeah yeah carve you up like a
Thanksgiving turkey come back here
now come back here you get back here I'm
not doing oh no I am doing fine that's
his hat that's his health Bartlet I'll
come back go don't boom don't run away
from Markey come here
I'm gonna call you smitty werben
jaegerman jensen just cuz I'm gonna call
everything smitty werben jaegerman I'm
actually winning how with a prison shank
I'm winning
that makes no damn Oh get down get down
hey hi right take your medicine there we
go I mean you could eat me at any time
your mouth is huge you could stuff me
right inside yourself like just slide me
right in
okay said good gotcha
there we go oh don't be so dramatic
what you're capable of
I just killed your thing with a prison
shank all right I did it good for me
oh yeah no no n-no oh do that another
one
no all right so anyway Oh a gun I could
have used this five minutes ago that's
what I said and a keycard cool all right
I got a boom banger oh that's so nice
that's actually nice
okay so the keycard goes back the wacky
why did I even come in this room if it
was just gonna be to my dad oh well
beggars wha oh okay yeah that was normal
oh good golly you die you've got a
tellin you die I gotta say this gun
doesn't seem to have very much punch to
it
Oh reload oh no I'm out already what was
even the point they just break around
him I'm still in psycho land
how do I get out oh oh you are
moderately disturbing
what's with the things that I've seen so
far they have they're like four arms and
four legs ripped off calves
oh that was you okay hey just died
please why are there so many of you I
would you know it would have been really
nice if you gave me ammo with that gun
but whatever cuz they don't need it my
prison shank is good enough another one
here I'm assuming that I have to kill
all of you because I need to get through
this place come on yo there we go
but if you cutscenes in this game I
didn't even know the D s could hold this
much data I mean obviously the
resolutions were much lower on the D s
and it was much more low end but still
damn there's a lot of stuff going on oh
hi oh oh oh hey buddy how you doing oh
goodness and you are naked very naked oh
the combats a little lackluster as far
as I can tell but man the area Oh God
disturbing like definitely oh man
reminds me a lot of stuff from like you
know when I first played doom my
imagination pumped up a lot of things
about it oh this door over here like you
know the decorations on the wall like
when I saw them it was like you know the
most realistic thing I've ever seen so
it was more more realistic than
something so this kind of is very
reminiscent of it like that I'm talking
about when you were in Hollywood
excuse me okay I'm back in the normal
world I think okay didn't mean to jump
there okay let me try to bat can I know
and he's like a hammer or something
anyway yeah I was talking about like all
these the the scenery and the stuff like
that is is pretty top-notch hey keycard
good for me okay maybe you should bump
me up to Code Red because I seem to be
doing a lot of bad stuff around here I'm
assuming that if all these demons came
from my head you guys are in for a lot
of trouble no I came out of nowhere you
didn't even say anything
yeah alright alright so anyway this has
been dimension 2 I'm gonna play a few
more episodes actually kinda like in the
game it's not bad at all I mean combat
is a little wonky but combat in horror
games there's always been a little wonky
but it's it's really not bad I mean I
mean it's I gotta find out more about I
want to play more so if you guys want to
see more I'm gonna make more and if you
guys want me to stop no
so anyway thank you all so much for
watching click the entities that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next
none of a [ __ ]